autre solution penser également dans les
yvelines au premier rang c'est le nom
d'une plateforme numérique d'entre aide
scolaire pour les collégiens et lycéens
elle a été lancée le 29 mars dernier des
élèves qui ne seront pas tous retournés
à l'école et qui sont mises en relation
directement avec des étudiants tuteurs
l'idée est de les accompagner dans
différentes disciplines un outil
développé par vous nouez leproust
bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes étudiant à
sciences po bordeaux originaire de
chevreuse déjà une question toute simple
pour commencer pourquoi avoir développé
cette plateforme au premier rang - dans
le cadre de ma formation j'étais à
l'étranger j'ai dû rentrer un petit peu
plus tôt à cause de la pandémie et au
bout d'une semaine voilà être en être
confiné chez moi je me suis aperçu de
par mes connaissances et puis mes soeurs
également avec qui j'étais que la classe
à distance était tout simplement quelque
chose qui était assez difficile à faire
et à suivre est aussi parfois pour bon
nombre d'élèves
oui c'est vrai qu'en termes de
continuité pédagogique que l'on a
entendu souvent pendant cette de
confinement avec forcément aussi le
problème de la fracture numérique qui ne
permettait pas tous les élèves de
pouvoir suivre les cours à distance est
important pour vous d'aider les élèves à
ne pas couper le contact finalement avec
leur établissement avec avait eu l'idée
avec l'éducation tout à fait voilà et
comme vous parler plus tard de fracture
numérique
on a sauté ce être le plus ouvert
possible et donc proposé aux tuteurs que
ça se fasse aussi bien par des
applications via ordinateur que par
l'utilisation d'un simple et smartphones
alors comment vous l'avez créer cette
plateforme est ce que vous avez fait
jouer vos relations vous avez contacté
peut-être d'anciens camarades de classe
comment comment ça s'est passé
oui ça tout à fait j'ai eu cette idée
donc j'ai appelé de 3000 pour en parler
et puis ça s'est fait très vite un site
avec un formulaire sur lesquels élèves
et twitter peuvent s'inscrire et ensuite
voilà j'ai décroché mon téléphone j'ai
appelé les anciens de mon métier j'ai
diffusé l'information également auprès
des de mes camarades à sciences po
bordeaux
et ça c'est très bien fait assez
rapidement je veux dire non le lien
s'affiche en bas de l'écran pour accéder
directement à cette plateforme comment
ça fonctionne concrètement comment
bénéficier d'un tutorat en ligne bah
tout simplement si vous avez besoin
vite d'avoir un tuteur une tutrice vous
remplissez un petit formulaire sur
lequel vous avez vous avez accès sur le
lien et avec ce formulaire là nous on va
recevoir votre demande et de l'autre
côté nous avons la même plate forme avec
le même formulaire pour les tuteurs et
notre rôle c'est vrai douala de faire
coordonner cette sorte de petit match
qui va être fait entre un élève édition
du terre c'est gratuit ce tutorat en
ligne tout à fait c'est le c'est un
point très important de notre plateforme
c'est entièrement gratuit
les étudiants sont bénévoles et voilà
l'idée c'est d'être le plus ouvert
possible et que le plus de personnes
puissent s'inscrire dans des élèves d'un
côté vous l'avez dit des tuteurs de
l'autre qui sont-ils justement ces
tuteurs et bien ce sont des étudiants
pour la plupart entrant ils sont en
première année jusqu'au quelques
doctorants également des élèves des
étudiants qui sont à la fois du sud
yvelines
voilà qui étudient dans la fac d'orsay
la fac de 50 ha le plateau de saclay et
puis voilà de dieu par le fait que
j'étudie mois aborde beaucoup
d'étudiants des sciences po bordeaux
également on l'a dit une plateforme
lancée depuis le 29 mars après plusieurs
semaines de fonctionnement quels sont
les les principaux besoins des
collégiens des lycéens que vous avez pu
relever ce qu'il ya des choses qui vous
et qui vous ont été remontés sur sur ses
besoins principalement ça va être
d'approfondir d'avoir un suivi
personnalisé auprès de notions qui
parfois sont difficilement abordable du
premier coup d'oeil du premier avis avec
le professeur donc ça va l'être que nous
pédagogie tout simplement de répétition
et de cette idée d' accompagnement
personnalisé qui normalement au sein
d'un établissement scolaire qui ne peut
plus faire malheureusement depuis le
confinement et où le même aujourd'hui
avec la reprise de façon assez partiel
est ce que les retours sont donc elle ce
qu'elle est le premier bilan que vous
pouvez dresser sur cette plateforme en
termes de bilan il ya beaucoup de gens
qui ont adhéré et que je remercie tout
évidemment pour l'élan de générosité qui
a eu on a une quarantaine de binômes qui
ont été formés depuis le début voilà et
puis avec des actions de communication
etc ont fait connect peu à peu notre
notre plateforme et nous avons été mis
en lien dernièrement avec la seat
éducatif de trappes
voilà pour développer un partenariat
auprès des élèves de l'urée gagarine au
collège de trappes j'allais finalement
terminer cet entretien avec vous là
dessus oui les liens avec la cité
éducative de trappes qui s'intéressent à
cette plateforme ils peuvent être amenés
à ceux à se développer c'est celle 1
c'est l'une des pistes de développement
en tout cas pour votre plateforme chat
pourra l'être en effet donc c'est un
projet qui est piloté à la fois par la
préfecture
l'académie de versailles et puis
évidemment la ville de trappes et donc
voilà pour nous c'est aussi l'occasion
de s'engager dans un autre pan un petit
peu du tutorat au delà du de notre
simple action et pourquoi pas à terme
effectivement s'engager sur sur le moyen
ou long terme avec ce collège mais plus
d'informations directement sur cette
plateforme en vous rendant sur la
plateforme au premier rang le lien
s'affiche en bas de l'écran merci
d'avoir été avec nous et le proust
fondateur d'autres premier rang et et
bravo pour cette initiative